oh hello welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very exciting to have caitlyn bristow on
today's episode i've done her podcast a
few times
and finally she is making her debut on
not too deep if you don't know her you
get ready to be impressed and exhausted
by how much this woman does
you might know her from bachelor nation
as the bachelorette
uh you might know her from instagram
she's all over there she's got a
scrunchie line
she's got two adorable golden retrievers
she's got a wine
label spaded sparrow she's got all kinds
of things going on
and most recently has been announced as
one of the official contestants on this
upcoming season of dancing with the
stars we talk all about what she's doing
to prep for that
we talk about what it's like to be in
the public eye
via a reality television show what it's
like to date her current boyfriend who
also came from said reality television
show franchise
it's a really fun exciting informative
episode so enjoy
not too deep with caitlyn bristow
[Music]
caitlyn thank you for being here this is
so fun this is so exciting
i've done your podcast a couple times
and now you get to be on not too deep
um so excited thank you for having me of
course now
anytime i have a guest that's kind of
like a very hybrid creative person i
like to ask them
what is your deal like how do you
describe
who you are and what you do to someone
that you've never met before
okay um well i uh
my name's caitlin bristow i feel like i
kind of got everything as a start from
being on bachelor bachelorette
and then from there i came off the show
and thought
how do i not just do flat tummy tea ads
for money
how do i actually build something and
have longevity in a career so i found
a team that is friends and business
people and they're all females
and we just really created um kind of a
brand for myself we sat down and thought
about what does she love
what are things that she that would make
sense for her to
you know be part of so we kind of um
i started my podcast so i'm a host of a
podcast called off the vine
i um i'm kind of a wine like
not snob i'll drink anything wine lover
you could say so i have my own wine
label
um i wear scrunchies in my hair every
day so i
started a scrunchie brand um and
that's pretty much yeah podcast yeah
you're this kind of a renaissance
creative entrepreneur
it's very inspiring and super cool to
watch
and interesting to hear that like there
was a concerted effort to like sit down
and figure out like what the game plan
was
after bachelor yeah because i think a
lot of
or i assume that like a lot of people
come off of that show and like you said
it's just like
i'll do whatever ad based stuff i can do
like you're thrown into this crazy
whirlwind of this
society this world this universe that
exists among itself
i totally get that people do that that
you know like it's
it's incredible money once you have a
platform and you don't even realize
like i i was on the bachelor in a time
where i didn't actually know
that was a thing on instagram that's
when it was kind of starting
so i was going on the show to be like oh
i'm gonna get instagram followers i was
kind of like holy hell and then you
could make money off that like what and
yeah so i don't blame them for doing it
nothing against the ads because i'm like
get your money it's amazing totally well
it's it's also like so
what what was the time frame that you
were on the bachelor what year was it
so 2015. yeah so this world in social
media is still evolving
and like that's the kind of moment i
think where people are realizing that
they can build brands they can like
build out and up
instead of just like laterally right i'm
curious what was the decision
to audition for the bachelor was it
a singular decision like by yourself was
it a group collective decision of other
people
influencing you it was one of those
things where i was so heartbroken and
like devastated from a breakup
where my girlfriend my best friend was
like let's sign you up for the bachelor
like i feel like so many people like
would say that but
i was like yo okay like not yeah
anything would ever come from it so
she was like determined that i was going
to go on the bachelor and she was like
i know it this is going to happen you're
going to go on the bachelor you're going
to fall in love but he's going to break
your heart you're going to come in third
and then you're going to be the
bachelorette
that's what she said so she predicted
all of this before it happened
yes it was okay this thing because i was
like
well no way i'm falling in love on the
bachelor that's so dumb
so there's no way they're gonna pick a
canadian
to like be the next bachelorette they
love the all-american
girl next door like there's no way but i
like where your head's at so anyways we
sent
everything paperwork photos all the
necessary
like audition videos and um
i never heard anything back and a year
went by
and i just was like didn't even think
like that was i just
had forgotten right idea
there's so much vulnerability in sending
all of this very personal stuff away to
like an unknown
you don't know the face of the person
that gets to take all this material in
and then you just sit in silence for a
year
pretending that you never did that right
like i was giving
like my um like they need your records
for like
excuse me um what is it like criminal
records if you've ever
like they need everything of you yeah
you as a human being and then you're
like no nothing
okay cool i'm cool too i didn't really
want this
so a year goes by and then you get a
phone call from someone
yeah so i was working at a restaurant
and
it was like a lunch break or something i
was back in the
lunch room at a restaurant i was working
at and i saw a missed call from like an
la number
i listened to the voicemail and she was
like hey this is so-and-so from casting
um with abc's the bachelor and i was
like
oh what you guys can call it a year
later
if i told her back and she was like yeah
are you single and i was like
kind of going on dates with a guy and i
literally was like
yep super into it anyways
and i was like yup and then again sent
in more
photos and paperwork and then they're
like we'd love to fly or
we'd love you to come in and like talk
at the office and i was actually going
to la with a girlfriend for vacation
and so i went there and met everybody at
the office and that's
how it happened and then the rest is
history that's so wild so it's basically
like you're dating this casting director
to get on this program to date these
other strangers
yes so nuts and i remember when
mamrie and i came and did your podcast a
couple years ago and
i'd never watched your season i was just
freshly new to the whole
bachelor nation scenario and it was so
interesting to hear you talk about
behind the scenes how
when you eventually became the
bachelorette that
there's like rolodexes of guys names and
that you have to go and refresh yourself
because it's edited obviously to make
you look like you
remember everyone and everything they do
constantly and you have this constant
dialogue in your head of exactly
charting every person's every move yeah
i'm
so fascinated about the bts of all of
that
the what do you if you could say is the
wildest thing that happens behind the
scenes
uh i think it's like the conversations
of like please don't make me make out
with this guy
yeah like you really because
i mean you want to like see romance
more with more than just one person when
there's 25 guys but like
right everything feels so wrong to you
at from your like moral compass and
everything that you've known your whole
life to like go
be this like you know make out with him
yeah like let's see what he it's just
doesn't right and i think those
funny conversations like behind the
scenes of like well you know if i kiss
him can i go to bed early tonight
yeah if i give you the moment that you
can
uh end this episode with i'm tired i'd
like snacks in bed please
yeah yeah i think it's uh yeah that's
pretty funny um
other behind the scenes like i mean i
just thought it was so funny that i
would walk into a room i am like
such a tomboy at heart and i would walk
into this room with these gowns i would
never wear my hair all done in these
this makeup that was so extravagant and
men would stand up and clap
and i was like my life like why are you
clapping
for me
and i'm like what is happening and then
i would go back to the hotel room or
wherever i was staying
i would literally rip them off like
thank god
bra off and i would just sweat and eat
beef jerky and put like zip cream on my
face and i was like man if they could
really see
the real kate one here oh i love it well
that's like
i've i'm i'm like kind of into bachelor
nation
and i think it's the funniest thing when
they refer to everyone as their
boyfriend or girlfriend and that they're
dating everyone and i'm like
you're kinda but okay i understand why
you have to frame it like this
it is so funny to me yeah like i don't
remember your name but you're my
boyfriend
yeah exactly exactly uh were you
a very outgoing like open person before
doing the show because i imagine like
there's a certain psychologically sound
person that can go through
that experience and come out the other
side still
functioning thriving well adjusted
because it seems like
it seems like you're like pulled inside
out and like shown to the world
hey here she is every nook and cranny
yeah um okay so my thought on this is
i mean thank god i went on in the time i
did because if i went on in my younger
20s i would have been just so
insecure and so fragile and like i
didn't have thick skin
i was always since i was little i've
always been an open book like
share i'm an over sharer i talk about
like how i'm feeling all the time like
that was no problem for me
uh but but just like going through that
process like they do they chew you up
and they spit you out
and you go through all of these crazy
emotions like they should definitely
have a therapist for after
yeah and and i'm to be honest probably
just as shocked as anybody that i am
okay afterwards
by the time when i came off the
bachelorette i was i mean
1 000 without a doubt depressed i was
engaged but nobody could know it i was
re-watching the season air where it was
super controversial at the time
and the person that i had picked was
just like
destroyed from it and having to relive
it because when you're on the show
you're like there's no way she has a
connection with other people like us
and you watch your back you're like what
um so i'm just like
constantly hurting the person i love i
had just been through like hell and back
on the show which is fun as it was it
was
an emotional roller coaster and i was
just drained and
then i'm just like living in this
apartment in vancouver where i'm like
what is gonna happen now i've got
everyone in their freaking
dogs calling me a [ __ ] and saying how
much they hate me
and i was just like people i'm the hated
bachelorette like
i i was just in a really dark place and
then i just kind of
went to my therapist talked through a
bunch of things with family and friends
and i was like
no i know who i am and i know what i
have to offer and i know that i'm not
what these people are saying and i'm
just gonna
i'm gonna use it to my advantage and i'm
gonna stand up for women around the
world who are like me
and make something of this and use my
platform for good and then i started
seeing more support and it did take a
while though to to wean out all the
cairns if you will
oh i'm sure i mean yeah because everyone
uh thinks that it's they're entitled to
your business that they're entitled to
opinions about your very personal
personal life because it's been
presented to them
uh well that they kind of are right like
they they are allowed to have their
opinions because i did put myself in
that position it doesn't mean they don't
hurt my feelings or that they're
like right you have to agree with them
but that's what's the hardest part is
like they're allowed to have those
opinions they're just so harsh sometimes
and uh yeah it's but they are allowed to
have those opinions the unfortunate part
is that your world is presented to them
in a way where you don't have the
control of the edit
which i think is from an audience
spectator kind of position that's why i
think what you do
online is so cool and important because
you have sort of transferred this public
image
into like a very authentic brand online
where you get to curate
how you appear to everyone and what you
share with everyone and how it's
presented
did you find social media
like comforting after all of that or was
there a time where you were like i don't
want to look at my phone i don't want to
see the internet i don't want to see
that i'm connected to anyone
yeah i mean i went through both uh right
after when
i actually found it funny at first
because i was like oh my gosh
like all these strangers who i don't
even know they don't even know anything
about me or like
saying these things about me like at
first i was like this is hilarious
yeah and i think the combination of like
being engaged
to somebody who was like definitely not
happy with me
um that was wearing so heavy on me that
the comments started getting to me and
it all just turned into this
nasty like spiral storm um yeah
but i actually remember saying this on
my snapchat because snapchat was really
big
when i came and it was really helpful
for me because i got to kind of explain
my side of things without
like going against a contract or like
ruining the show and
i was like this is so nice because i
actually get to just be myself
on this video and like share that with
people because that wasn't really a
thing
that people could do in past seasons
right there wasn't snapchat um i think
before my season and then there wasn't
even instagram stories until
after snapchat so yeah um yeah i i
actually really loved that aspect of it
with being able to
to just be myself and have still a
pretty big audience watching
yeah did you also with that i feel like
you know once you're part of bachelor
nation it's a very
like um a very tight-knit group of
people because it's a very
unique experience that you guys all
share with each other
is watching the show now enjoyable for
you does it feel kind of like work that
you have to do
to like maintain your membership of the
bachelor nation or
is it just actually enjoyable um it took
a couple
years i sure i don't know i hate
sounding so dramatic and like
poor me but i honestly had trauma from
the show
and like obviously this isn't i think
that you don't need to apologize for how
you feel about this
it is so wild that i think people
forget that you're a human being kind of
being puppeteered through this system
for
the purpose of everyone's entertainment
like it is
it's weirdly uh this is dramatic to say
but i think it's kind of along the lines
of like
you know roman like coliseum days where
you like bring
lions and like gladiators out and you're
like watch them all struggle
and enjoy it and that's what reality tv
is that's exactly right like before i'd
watch the bachelor i was such a fan and
i would just laugh
and be like these people are ridiculous
yeah yeah
and then after i was like i can't even
watch um
i mean it was went into next season
which he was the one that proposed to me
so i was like i don't
like too soon too soon it's a little too
triggering yeah yeah and then it was ben
who was also on my sister and i was like
still too soon
yeah so i didn't watch those seasons i
wan i watched a little bit of jojo's
just because i wanted to be supportive
of the bachelorette after me and like
give her support um for sure but that
was really hard for me
now i love watching it again i love
talking about it i love watching it
um i definitely watch it through a
different lens with like so much
compassion for these people
yeah i mean it is so wild and it only
gets crazier the more connected we all
are with social media too like it's it's
insane and the links that they have to
go to to keep everything secretive
you know i don't know how they do it it
blows my mind it truly blows my mind
um but now you've parlayed this into
like a
beautiful life like just looking at your
instagram it's uh you got so many things
going on for you
and the most recent is that you're going
to be on dancing with the stars
which i know has been a long dream a
very exciting
and finally something you're able to do
because like everything else there was a
lot of like uh
legalese and restrictions going on with
that beforehand
right so does it feel a little bit like
before you even get on the show like a
victory
yes um it felt like a victory when
hannah
brown went on it for me because i was
so passionate about speaking out on the
fact that they kept letting their
bachelor's go on and not the
bachelorettes
and i mean i know they did trista went
on and
she was season one and that's i mean
that was the first season they've ever
done and i think she's already out of
contract actually at that
point but so she went on and then it
just kept being like
sean lowe and then chris souls and then
they didn't let me
and they said you know you'll no um
no one that comes on our show will be
will be going on dancing with the stars
anymore like it's just not
good for anyone this was like they had a
personal vendetta against you
specifically they're like okay her
season's done let's bring two of the
guys from her season
on the next couple seasons and let them
uh be beloved by the world and then
let's also keep her from doing the one
thing she really wants to do
yes that was the thing and i was like
imagine having the power
to have somebody's dreams come true and
having the power to crush them
and choosing to crush their dreams like
imagine that
and so i was you know everyone knows i
took it to twitter we had a little bit
of a war with the creator of the show
but
we've we've come to full circle um
and i think i'm just really proud that i
said something and
you know because that did get me kind of
blacklisted from the show for a while
and um i was kind of like well i'm
that's who i am like i like to stand up
for myself and
and what i think is right even if it's
gonna give me less opportunity to be on
television like that's i have to think
about what matters
and so um i just continued to stand
strong in that and i just have such a
supportive group of you know
podcast listeners and followers that
they kept saying stuff too
and i feel like my followers almost like
didn't lose the dream either with me
and then first of all you know i've had
the conversation
with um with fleiss and i've like
mended broken fences at abc i actually
like
love them dearly and we just have such a
solid relationship
now um and and so when they
offered that to me i was just like you
know what this feels right
the timing feels right i don't think i
would have been um mentally
capable of doing tv right after doing
that show i don't know
how hannah did it um and one it was
i just like bow down to her for that but
yeah it's it's
it's just perfect timing and everything
about it feels right and i've got the
best support system and i'm just like
mentally in a good place and physically
i've been working up
kids i was gonna yeah okay we're gonna
take a quick break i want to hear
all about what you've been doing
mentally and physically to prep for
for this new season so we'll be right
back with more not too deep
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things one
thank you so much for listening and two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a um review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
okay we're back so not only uh
are you from this very popular franchise
moving on to dancing with the stars
you're also a dancer like you've this is
in your dna well
that's the part that actually scares me
the most because i think people
know like my title when i came out of
the limo
on the bachelor was dance instructor
and i'm like well i haven't danced in
like five years but okay
sorry sure yeah so i was like that's the
title they went with okay
um so everyone has thought of me as a
dancer and i mean i did i grew up
dancing
and i it's like my dream i love dancing
more than anything my happy place is in
a dance studio
um but now i just think that's so much
pressure that i'm going in and people
are like well she's a dancer so she's
gonna do good
and i'm like but i've never done
ballroom and it's
so much different so i'm like
but like don't think of me as a dancer
just like yes and like
i mean i can still pick up you give me a
hip-hop routine and i'll have the eight
counts down and like
like that but to be in a
ballroom um situation like i don't even
know
how to do a waltz or like look i don't
know anything and i know that they don't
do eight counts that i'm used to
um certain dance moves do toe heel and
other ones are heel toe
and it's like just a complete different
world so i'm like
so like i hope my memory is there with
picking up steps
um and i have rhythm of course but my
god what if i'm just like the laughing
joke of the show like
she was a dancer well that's i mean
that's the big appeal of that show too
is that you have this like
wide net of types of people that compete
and then you're shocked or delighted or
disappointed by the way people show up
for the show
what have you been doing to prep because
when does when do you actually start
filming um so we don't know exact dates
yet all i know
is i'm heading out there at the end of
august to hopefully start rehearsals
um so i i mean i am
i am a machine right now and i am proud
to say that because i've been working
so hard jason jason's like
oh my gosh you i've like never seen you
like this because
i was i was um i mean i'm 35 and i
am i feel like i'm just i've done things
that i wanted to do in my life i really
truly believe i had one more thing deep
down in me that i was like i need to do
one more thing and it's totally dance
it's full circle
like gave up dance is a dream to chase a
boy and like lost
everything and like now i'm like i'm
getting chills
i feel like this is a new indie rom-com
that could be written right now
seriously and then it's like she's back
in 35
better than ever yeah i was like i just
want to be
in the best shape of my life before i
have kids like i
really want my next step to be family
and i'm like
just hoping that that happens for me but
i was like i want to be in the best
shape and then when i found out that i
was like this is a perfect opportunity
i'm going to get so strong
i am going to like mentally and
physically just be the strongest i
possibly can so i've been doing
like serious uh weightlifting with a
trainer who's like trained
the titans and like the nashville
predators like he's like
trainer for athletes holy [ __ ] you're
going for it
i like injured my back i was like i'm
like dude i can't come on wednesday like
i totally injured my back he goes no
caitlyn welcome to dead lifting it's
called your sore you're not injured
and i wasn't i was just that sore that i
thought i couldn't move
so i've been doing that for about 12
weeks i've been doing physical therapy
for
mobility and like strength and she'll
put these goggles on me
that athletes do um for balance
so they're these goggles that have
strobe lights and then i'll balance on
one foot with the strobe lights one and
she'll throw lacrosse balls at me and i
have to like try and catch them because
i'm working on my balance
and then um i've been boxing for like
you know like my quick moves and my
footwork and
stamina and then i've been riding my
peloton bike and i've just been like
in the zone where on sundays that's a
different story but like
monday through saturday i'm like really
trying to be aware of i mean i'm still
drinking
so much wine but sure it's all part of
the brand
yeah it's you know it's called research
and development
it's work but it's also a treat because
i'm like i'm going hard like give me a
glass of wine
really prepping and and this is just
like could you imagine i go home night
one and i'm just like
i went to the crystal store today and i
got all these like manifesting crystals
i got a safe
blessing i'm like going in all ripped
like yeah
we're like sorry caitlyn you didn't get
enough votes
you'll be voted off in the best shape of
your life
that's i mean so you're doing truly
mental
physical spiritual training for all of
this
wow that's very intense is there
um a dance that you're the most
nervous or concerned about or just all
of them
all of them i i feel like i would be
excited for like
do they even do the tango i feel like i
love the tango i
i feel it sounds like a cha-cha yeah
that's what i really want to do i i'm
really nervous for the
um the jive and salsa because
i know a few people that have gone on
the show and they say that was the most
difficult
okay well it feels like you've been
doing a lot of like game day training
like you are
getting in the zone i feel like this is
like your rocky montage right now of all
the different things that you're doing
up front documenting this and like put
it in a video for me
right that would have been like that
that would have made it worth it if i do
go home night one that would have been
hilarious
amazing amazing but so on top of this
you talked about drinking wine
you have your own wine label uh
how did this come about because your
podcast your podcast also
drinking wine all of it goes hand in
hand did this happen
before podcast after podcast so
this was something that when i was
working in the restaurant industry i
used to train servers and have to be
really knowledgeable about the wine list
and pairing it with food and i always
loved
learning about wine and knowing about
wine and tasting life
and it was just something that i was i
fell in love with it was probably
one of the only reasons i really stayed
in the restaurant because i was just so
fascinated by it
and then so after working at a
restaurant
i was like oh that would be a dream to
have like a wine label so when i went on
the show
and came off the show
i was like i need to do something around
wine
and then yeah past happened it was off
the vine oh i'll drink wine
and you know have like a social fun hang
with somebody and all my guests will
drink wine and we'll just like
shoot the [ __ ] yeah and i was like
um after about three years of doing the
podcast
i think no two two years of doing the
podcast somebody was like
why don't you have your own wine label
and i was like why the hell do i not
have my own one
that of course is my next move yeah well
if i thought you know i'm an influencer
i could slap my name on a wine and
i'll like of course love the guy and but
i was like
i really want to be um invested in it i
want to put my money where my mouth is i
want to invest all my own money
into it and put that all down myself i
want to be part of every business call
and i'm still thinking that was going to
be fun which it is but
i did not realize the amount of work
that goes into this like just
shipping alone with different states and
different laws
and the manufacturers and the like
labels and corks and picking all these
different things and the
distribution and trying to convince
people to carry my wine and
right right it's crazy how much work
goes into it
um but it's just been the most like
rewarding for me because
i mean it's wine it's something i'm
passionate about and i really feel like
like i guess silver lining in 2020 is
that
i got to actually be home and really um
be a part of the businesses that i
that i own i just feel like i was more
involved and it's been like really
rewarding
yeah because that's i i know that you
were you were doing a tour you were
doing like live shows
and you were like on the move it felt
like constantly um
before quarantine and everything
happened
did and it's nice to hear that like
quarantine actually
in a positive way gave you a moment to
like sit with all of your
the branded stuff and figure everything
out and like be really up close to it
and a part of it
um is there development in the wine side
for
other bottles other types
yeah so right now we have a rose a pinot
grigio and a pinot noir
we're really wanting to bring back the
cab because people loved it
um and i'm wanting to do like you know a
holiday
wine or a reserve bottle but we also
have so many fun exciting
different things that you wouldn't think
of when it comes to wine
um that we haven't like really
figured out just yet we're working out
the kinks and and trying to like see how
we can do this
um but stay tuned for that because i
it's gonna be cool
yeah are we talking like inventing
something
that oh very cool
because uh i feel like now is the time
for everyone to adapt and
uh innovate in a lot of ways so
it's very exciting to hear that because
also like
like you said you have your scrunchie
line you've you're dabbling with music
now look at that too yeah uh
you have two beautiful dogs uh that
are adorable are they coming with you to
train when you start training
yeah they're coming so jason and the
dogs are coming
and because they're both emotional
support animals
as soon as i got ramen i actually got
paperwork and stuff because
i mean i'm very honest about struggling
with uh anxiety
and anxiety on the planes was a really
new thing for me i used to
love love flying i used to think like
what a gift i can just sit back in a
chair
fly through the air and drink wine and
watch a movie like yeah yeah
like the longer the flight the better
and then i don't know what shifted in me
and
it something came over me in the last
couple years of traveling where
i feel trapped i start getting like hot
and anxiety
yeah like weird things go through my
head and so
um yeah ramen definitely helps me on
flights he's
the best traveler he's just a little
angel on planes he just curls up in a
little like
croissant at my feet and like ah he's
just an
angel and then pinot is also but pino's
never been on a plane before so
jason's taking him and i'm like good
luck with that that'll be his
first plane experience yeah and pino's
like um
very unpredictable ramen's very
predictable like i know exactly what
he's going to do and how he is and what
to do to calm him down he knows just
like all over the map and he like
howls at random sounds i don't know he's
just like
i'm pretty sure he pooped on the floor
this morning he hasn't like
he's so potty trained i don't even know
like he's just so unpredictable yeah
oh no and especially in quarantine my
dog has also become like
so wildly codependent and so confusing
with her emotions that i
i can't predict anything that she's
gonna do now it's very strange
um what was the catalyst to get the
first
golden retriever ramen was first yeah
ramen okay first
i have since i was little i've loved
golden retrievers
and that was oh i had a golden retriever
in my last relationship that i was
so obsessed with that when when we broke
up i was like
i can't handle not seeing this dog like
i'm like not okay and so i was like well
i'll just have to get my own
um and then jason hadn't even moved in
yet and i was following bunny's buddies
on instagram which is an organization
out of um san diego but they
rescue dogs um from south korea and
china from like
the meat industry oh wow yeah so i was
following
their account just like wanting to help
all these dogs and so i would put them
on my instagram stories being like hey
if you want to help donate to this
surgery or whatever
and then i saw ramen and they were like
we found this little guy on the side of
the road
and like he had a broken leg and a
fractured pelvis from being
kicked they thought and i was like
oh god and his name is and i was just
like
oh he came with the name ramen and i was
just in love with him
instantly and so i started donating to
his surgery and i was like
he needs to get better yeah telling
everybody and then i said to jason like
i'm like such a
weirdo with um signs from the universe
and like
it's meant to be and having gut feelings
and i just
feel like this is my dog like i need him
and jason was like no no that
you're we are not every week like
there's no way
and i was like well like maybe i can
talk to a therapist and see if i could
get him to be emotional support animal
that could travel and he's like it's a
golden retriever he's gonna be huge
he's only like 45 pounds he's so little
wow
yeah he's small and so i just was like
look i'm getting this dog and you're
moving
your report on this and he was like okay
here we go
there we go well he flew all the way
from south korea
and he uh poor thing could barely walk
on his back leg and we had to take off
he took him in physical therapy every
week he'd like walk in water and like
he's just started getting so much
stronger and then and then
we just were like we need another one we
need another
and they get along the two pups get
along i swear they might be brothers
they're from the same
um organization they both stay at the
same shelter
and um they just are very similar
okay when the reason we got pinot is
because
the the lady called me and she goes we
have ramen 2.0 like this is literally
ramen
in a different dog like it's crazy and i
was like wow
and then and jason again was like i
don't know and it surprised me and got
pinot and like
oh that was just yeah yeah it was
awesome
that's so cute have you done the dog dna
test at all to see if they are related
yes so we did do the dna test um
they both have so many similar relatives
okay some close some not i don't know
i'm like convinced they have the same
dad
yeah that's what i'm going for brothers
i love that uh they seem super sweet so
they're going to be out here potentially
there's a
opportunity to dance with the dogs you
know what let's just
throw it out there yeah right dancing
with dogs
i would love that is there other than
dancing with the stars are there any
other reality
programs that you could see yourself on
um um big brother really
and i have always been a huge nerd for
big brother i mean like
i force friendships on all of them when
they come off the show
i might have to be friends um i like
watch the live feeds like i have
um wow brother pools with friends not
this year but i usually do
i love that show and i would love to be
on it like that i auditioned for that
show too
but they don't take canadians wow really
yeah that's so interesting why don't
they take canadians does
canada have their own franchise the
voice
um american idol does but the voice
doesn't
which is interesting yeah weird oh but i
can see you on that show
i mean that'd be great i could also
would you and jason ever do like amazing
race or anything like that
yeah we've talked about that i think i
would love to we both would love to do
amazing race
oh yeah i feel like you guys would be
great at that
i feel like we'd make such a solid team
like i'm i'm like
i think people would think i'm a baby
with certain things like
bugs or like eating i feel like i could
do that
and like i'm pretty fearless with
certain things and jason's like
the most intelligent human being on the
planet and like could direct us
everywhere and he would do
your thing so i'm like wouldn't it be so
good yeah that'd be great
um whenever the world opens back up i
could see that happening
right do you because you guys are both
from the bachelor
nation world do you feel
or do you have like any unspoken rule
over like the privacy of your personal
relationship
that's a really good question because
first of all i don't think anyone's
really asked us that and it's
actually a topic in our relationship
quite often because yeah
at first when we met he is um i was
shocked
like getting to know him i'm like i
can't even believe you went on that show
like it's just
seemed like it's it's just so out of
character and his his family they're
just the most incredible people and
they're like
they're they're just classy people
yeah and you're like why how about you
uh and so i know like when i first met
him like his mom said to him
are you sure you can keep up with
caitlyn like she's a firecracker
and he was like oh no
he can by the way but it was just very
new to him and the family i think to be
so public and to share things and
it had already come so naturally to me
in life
um and then on my podcast like i'll talk
about anything and everything
and so um a really actually crazy story
was
he just was like not used to that and we
talked about something
on one of my live podcasts and i said
like i was on my period i said that like
we were dry humping and i was like
laughing about it because like who does
that
yeah and then i said and they picked my
nose like we're there like we do we do
all the things and that actually got
picked up by a media
um and his job he was um
you know he was vp of a bank in seattle
and
i mean he handled it so well because
he's like well first
of all because they were kind of like
you know if you're in this banking world
like
these kind of headlines and which is so
clear
um but which is also but also like
he's already been on the bachelorette
like
he's a public person now exactly and so
it
like he was gonna have to eventually
deal with something like that but sure
but he was just like look i was having
consensual sex with my girlfriend
and she said it not me like there's
really no issue here and they were kind
of like
very valid and very fair but he ended up
leaving anyways but
like because he was moving here but it
was just so
interesting because it's like what can
you do what can you do
what a wonderfully awkward headline
article
for that conversation to have happened
in the
professional setting it was a wild time
but i think he's kind of getting used to
it but that was
definitely a conversation in our
relationship of like can you not share
so much and i'm like but why it's so
relatable
but this is my brand yeah i can't i
don't keep secretly my brand i talk
about
embarrassing [ __ ] all the time
but that's great i mean yeah because
it's it feels like you guys have a very
solid relationship that flows naturally
because there's like a respect between
you guys and a respect for your actual
private relationship
especially because you both have been
through that like
microscope of bachelor nation stuff and
now you get to control your narrative
yes it gets picked up by a random
website here and there
it's so crazy because even his family
they've just gotten so
comfortable with it and they kind of
understand just who i am now as a person
like i'm
not a bad person his like his mom
she watched my um season with me when it
aired as like the reunion and like the
little three-hour special
and she was like you've got this like
we're gonna get through this together
and i'm like
what party this is amazing
that's very sweet okay we're gonna take
one last break
when we get back i have some twitter
questions for you so we'll be right back
with we're not too deep
so caitlin before we get into these
twitter questions i'm going to ask you
the two questions i ask every single
guest that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most
like to throw cold spaghetti at oh yeah
i forgot you do that question
um i would like to throw cold spaghetti
oh
um do you say dead or alive dead or
alive and
it's with the knowledge that this answer
could change on a regular basis it's
just who today comes to mind
my like heart for some reason won't say
oprah just just to see how she reacts
because i i love her who doesn't know
yeah the planet that'd be like i'm gonna
throw it in her face because i don't
like her like
i'm doing it because i think she's just
the most kind of soul who would like
find a reason as to why i did that and
then talk me through it
yeah i feel like she would turn that
into like one of the
like commercials where she's like carbs
and just throw spaghetti everywhere yeah
yeah i feel like we would bond over it
yeah i feel like that'd be a really good
marketing tool for
no definitely make headlines yes
okay the other question i ask every
guest is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story
or close call but you can only use three
words or small phrases
um or a combination of words and small
phrases so mine
for example is college jogging front
lawn
okay mine is
new york oh first time meeting jason's
parents
karaoke bar oh no
oh that's a very vivid memory
there's a lot going on there
oh this city that never sleeps um
okay no follow-up questions to that we
can all fill in our own blanks about
what might have happened
uh let's get into some twitter questions
um okay someone wants to know why the
bachelorette were you going to actually
find love
or was it more like [ __ ] it let's see
what happens
yeah um bachelor i was more [ __ ]
let's see what happens
yeah it's like definitely interested in
like just doing something else after i
was like what could i
do from that like that would open doors
for me not believing in the process
i got there then i believed in the
process because i was like oh dang i
actually did fall
somewhat in love with this person um and
then i believed it could happen for me
as the bachelorette so going into the
bachelorette i actually really did do it
because i thought i could follow him up
okay yeah i mean i guess when you're
there and you're
in the process it's hard to deny what's
happening
yeah i was like oh okay i see why girls
cry on night one cool
yeah yeah i'm deprived of all of my
things and made to stay awake for
over 24 hours okay yeah alcohol
yeah see you tomorrow uh
okay someone wants to know who do you
want to be partnered with on dancing
with the stars
anyone i yeah who do i really want dare
cuff but he's not there anymore
so that i like have this is so creepy
and i hope he doesn't ever
hear this story but i have actually
had dreams that i've danced with him
because i met him
i was the bachelorette and i was on good
morning america doing something
he was on good mor good morning america
because they were announcing the cast
for the new dancing with the stars
and he dipped me for a picture and
from then on i've like had vivid dreams
about dancing with him so
i always thought that was gonna happen
and now i'm like
dang he's not there anymore okay so now
i'm like i really like val
i really like sasha um
and um i'm like blanking on other
people's names but i i won't i won't be
upset at anyone who i get
do you know how you get told who you're
paired with
is it like a surprise do they announce
it live i think it's a surprise like i
don't think we know until we go there
okay okay well cool fingers crossed who
knows there's still time for derek to
come back and make a
sweeping shocking surprise not like
world of dance the show he's on though
like it's different oh yeah
isn't it fair very fair no i'm not i'm
not losing hope until
yeah uh someone said no will we be
getting more music
yes oh my gosh i just recorded a new
song um
i just wrote a new one yesterday and i
recorded a new one last week
and i wrote a song for jason and it's
like i'm like really not
a um words of affirmation kind of person
in a relationship but if you ask me like
write it down
i can so it was like a really beautiful
process to like write out
our story and like sing what i was
feeling to him
um and and then record it i'm like i'm
really proud of it
oh that's so sweet and also what a a
different
avenue have you always been into music
um so growing up i was always doing song
and dance singing and dancing was like
my favorite thing in the world i was in
like a couple musicals um and then
when i moved to nashville i was like i
just like singing i liked to do as a
hobby i actually did it back in
vancouver too i just took lessons on the
side because i loved doing it
yeah so i did that here and then i
started finding myself being in the same
circle as songwriters and country
singers and
like people are like oh we should write
one time and i'm like i don't know how
to write music and they're like
it's co-writing you you just tell us
like what you're feeling we can help you
put it into a song and i was like okay
and i started falling in love with that
and then i just i i actually
i was on broadway for a hot minute there
singing and hosting
um a christmas show on broadway yeah and
so i was like
i i say this all the time and i'm like
i'm pretty sure my mic was turned off
like i'm like
just totally fine but i've always just
loved to sing so now that i'm like
actually doing it and people were
enjoying it i was like
what oh you guys like yeah yeah it's
cool
it also sounds like a very therapeutic
process to just sort of
talk out how you feel and then and you
will shape it into a song
yeah you're with strangers who are all
so like artistic and like
totally open to vulnerability because
that like makes good music
and so you don't get stupid saying
anything
wow that's really cool let's do that
like they're so talented out here oh my
gosh that's
awesome and way to get like the best use
out of the city that you live in
it's perfect i love it uh someone to
know well
speaking of you being in the united
states how much do you miss canada right
now
again another vivid dream i have is
going back to canada i
i'm like obviously so i feel so
fortunate to be in the states and get to
have a work visa and be here and like
america has done so much for me um but i
am like such a true canadian and i
usually go back home
for a month every summer i usually go
home other times but for a summer i
usually go for a full month and like not
be there right now and seeing the
memories on my
um instagram like one year ago yeah
we're out on the lake with your family
and i'm like
no i've gone without seeing family so
i'm just like yeah
i miss canada i can totally see myself
raising a family there
uh i mean yeah that you have the lucky
scenario of
being a citizen of canada to go back
yeah uh someone to know what's a bigger
dating red flag
they sing every sentence they say out
loud or they literally cannot whisper
interesting um i feel like jason does
sing
every sentence he says um which
sometimes i'm like that's funny and
sometimes
please stop um whisper one because then
he would be careful of what he says
ah yeah yeah that's very true very true
also i just think it's funny that
someone like can't actually whisper
hilarious okay here's the last question
because i feel like you're
very wonderfully open about dealing with
anxiety
daily living your life kind of out loud
online
someone wants to know what are good ways
to manage your own toxic behaviors
oh i've got a list um
uh well one one thing that's actually
just
really helped me was being aware of them
like
i would pretend they weren't happening
before where now i'm like oh my gosh
caitlyn this is that thing that you do
where you go out of your own body and
act like a child
and like yeah like come back to yourself
you like have the tools now to
not do that um so i think being aware of
it helps me
um i am such a believer in meditation
because since i've done meditation which
has been probably
three years now um my overall
just like demeanor has been more calm
and
i can find ways to come out of that
toxic way of thinking quicker
um do you use any specific apps or
um yeah yeah i really love that one i'm
like
obsessed with tamara's voice it's just
like it puts me to sleep all the time
um exercise is a big one for me which i
never wanted to believe before these
last 12 weeks but
it i am a different person mentally from
that you just have more like
i don't know clarity and energy and just
like the endorphins thing is real
and honestly i go so regular
uh regularly to my therapist and she
she just knows me so well at this point
and my you know
reasons for why i do certain things i do
or why i react certain ways
and so talking through that with
somebody even if it's not a therapist
like talking through your toxic
behaviors with somebody
and knowing that like in the moment of
this happening
yeah it feels impossible it feels
absolutely impossible to come out of it
but you just have to like every day is
uh has got to be um an effort like
you can't think you're going to be
healed yeah from that kind of behavior
you just every day it's going to be a
constant effort and
um a practice that you do every day yeah
i'm with you i feel like just the
the the effort to acknowledge it it
makes such a huge difference on a
regular
basis instead of just sort of like
letting it continuously exist and hoping
magically someone's wand will come and
hit you and it goes away
um you're an ongoing project in your own
self
for your whole life totally that's all
really wonderful advice
uh well before we wrap up completely
usually when we do the podcast in person
we give a gift to our guests which is a
personalized fortune cookie from us to
you
but because we're doing this remotely we
have a digital fortune cookie
that we've sent you that i think melissa
might have emailed to you
oh my gosh fun i'm so excited
oh i got it okay what a good idea
they're cute okay it says
the monkey writing this fortune is about
one and a half bottles of spade and
sparrows deep
in and what does that mean deep in and
witty
oh i think it just gets a little drunker
as you read on
kidding getting
chardater harder to get the words out
no you're drunk wow
that animal we don't mistreat the
animals that work here on the not to do
podcasts we allow them to imbibe in any
of the
uh sins that they want to experience
uh really great caitlyn this has been so
fun
where can people find you and everything
that you are doing because you're a very
busy lady before you make
the the trip west and start your
adventure on dancing with the stars
well thank you for having me you are so
good at what you do and i love being on
um and so i'm basically caitlin brisso
everywhere like instagram twitter
um i'm like snapchat do i even use that
don't
snapchat anymore i'm like it's been a
while um what do we do now what's the
name oh tick tock yuck
that's just what comes to mind when i do
tick tock uh and then
i mean everything if you want to buy the
wine um
it's my at spade and sparrows on
instagram
um but everything's on caitlyn
bristow.com as well you can shop
the scrunchies and the wine and that's
probably a good place for everybody to
go
awesome check out everything that she's
doing guys there's something for
everyone and get ready for the next
season of dancing with the stars because
you gotta call in and vote i forget how
they do it you could text you could you
have to do so many swipe ups i'm gonna
be so
because i'm like everybody's fingers
better be just numb from voting
get ready thank you again caitlyn and we
will see you guys on another episode of
not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music